this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm really happy to be here
this afternoon and share a little bit of
what I've been doing at Cornell for the
past year and so Don just gave an
introduction to what I'm doing here I'm
an anthropologist by training and I'm
taking advantage of this opportunity
that the NSF offers for social
scientists to gain experience in fields
outside of their major field and so
whenever I talk about the lost crops of
eastern North America it requires a lot
of exposition because most people have
never heard of them so I'm gonna kind of
start at the beginning and give you a
little brief interview to interview
introduction to how archaeologists
convinced ourselves and others that
these are indeed lost crops that some of
them were domesticated and then take you
through some aspects of my dissertation
research that led me to the questions
that I have about the role of plasticity
and domestication which is what I'm
exploring here and at the end I'll show
you some of the very kind of preliminary
observations or some of the things that
I've been doing here our plants are
still in the field right now so we'll be
harvesting them soon and then we'll have
more results from this year so first of
all my background what I've been trained
in is paleo ethnobotany which is a
sub-discipline of archaeology paleo
obviously stands for old I analyze
ancient plant remains that are recovered
from archaeological sites usually in my
case seeds and fruits but other small
fragments as plants will do um as know
as people so ethno botanist talked to
people a lot I sometimes talk to people
but because I study ancient agriculture
I'm more often will read historical and
ethnographic records to understand how
it really how a culture worked in the
past and then botany I don't think
really needs an introduction in this
crowd so just to kind of give you an
intro to how we get the types of plant
remains that I'm that I analyze or that
I specialize in and it's it's extremely
simple it's a method called flotation so
basically when we find context where
plant remains are likely to be found
such as this hearth which the flotation
sample has already been removed from
this floor that has tiny pieces of
charcoal embedded in it or this area
around a grindstone those seem like good
places to find plant remains we take a
soil sample and we process it by
floatation which basically just means
that we pour
into a bucket or a bin of water agitate
it and then pour off the organic
material that floats to the top so
that's my students are doing here
they're skimming the organic material
into a cheesecloth which we then dry out
it's very high-tech and we bring it back
to lab to analyze it so hopefully once
we picked out all the sort of roots and
modern seeds and things from the sample
that are not of interest to us what
we're left with is ancient plant remains
that were left behind by people and
because I study domestication I usually
take this one step further and take
micro photographs or some sort of images
of these seeds and fruits and then
analyze them to see if there's been any
change over time in the size and shape
of the fruits or if there's any
differences geographically and so this
happens to be the species that I studied
for my dissertation just to give you an
idea of kind of what my data looks like
there's a lot of variability obviously
but there's also variability how
well-preserved these are these are all
exceptionally well-preserved which is
why I bothered photographing them in the
first place but you can see that they're
not perfect and so another big aspect of
what I do is kind of trying to
reconstruct what they look like before
they were burned and buried in the
ground for a 2,000 years but I'm not
really going to talk much about how we
do that today because it's actually very
boring so domestication is what I
specialize in and the way that I define
that is a co-evolutionary relationship
where human practices are changing the
bodies and behaviors of plants and
animals and of course if it's a call
evolutionary relationship I strongly
believe that our relationships with
these plants and animals are also
changing our bodies and behaviors over
the course of thousands of years so the
reason why I chose these two images to
represent domestication is because these
were two very simple experimental
projects that taught us very important
lessons about how to massification works
so in the case of volumes Fox
experiments what he did was he just
selected wild foxes on one specific
trait which was lack of aggression
towards people and what ended up
happening over the course of several
generations is that a whole suite of
other traits that our domesticated man
will share things like shorter birth
intervals piebald codes floppy ears all
these different things that many of our
domesticated animals have ended up kind
of coming along with just the selection
for that one trait and so the
locations of this you know have been
really important people are still doing
research about how that works in our
domesticated mammals today and then
Hillman's experiments with wheat showed
that um if you exert really strong
selective pressure on wild wheat through
harvesting methods you can actually
domesticate it very rapidly so in both
cases it was a very simple experiment
that that showed us something really
fundamental about domestication and I've
really taken a lot of inspiration from
studies like these in my own work so
this is the eastern agricultural complex
in this case eastern is referring to
eastern North America east of the Great
Plains and these are the plants that
people grew here in pre-columbian times
so some of these crops obviously are
familiar to us maize beans and squash
were and continue to be extremely
important to indigenous people that are
from Eastern Asian North America but the
wild progenitors of these plants are not
from eastern North America they were
first domesticated in what is now Mexico
and they reached the region where I work
around 900 AD incidentally it was
probably a little bit earlier in New
York that's a story for another day
and quite mysterious the plants that
were domesticated in eastern North
America from native while janitors are
other squashes like acorn squash and
sunflower that we still grow today but
the other five plants on this slide are
the lost crops so those are the species
that I'm studying and that I'm growing
right now so this is just they're sort
of in chronological order here from when
they entered the crop system so these
were the earliest followed by they're
both saw maturing pseudo cereals so non
non grass seed crops to spring maturing
grasses and then erect not weed entered
the crop system last probably around
2,500 years ago this is the area where
we have really good evidence that these
plants were grown we call it the core
area because there's not a good name for
it and like 21st century
geography like it's not really the
Midwest it's not exactly the southeast
but it made a lot of sense as a region
to ancient people because of the rivers
so it's basically centered on the
Mississippi River and includes most of
its important northern tributaries and
then there's two highland areas that are
on the periphery of this core area and
they've been really important
because we get better preserved plant
remains from caves and rock shelters and
so a lot of the evidence that I'll talk
about and all of the evidence that we
have that we can get ancient DNA out of
comes from music peripheral highland
areas so I like to start talked about
this that aren't for archaeologists by
just explaining how we know that these
are lost crabs so that everyone doesn't
spend the whole time talking being
skeptical it all started with flotation
in the 1960s and one of the first things
that archaeologists started to notice is
they would excavate contacts like this
which is the bottom of a storage pit the
last 10 centimeters or so which are just
this dense layer of burnt plant remains
and in this case what this turned out to
be was a homogeneous mass of millions of
erect not weed seeds now this is one of
the assemblies that I analyzed for my
dissertation so I can also tell you that
it's from a domesticated population
which is an independent line of evidence
that these were cultivated plants and
I'll talk more about that in a second
but even just from the context this is
not the kind of thing that we would
expect to find if people were just you
know had these plants growing around and
we're occasionally using them this is
something that we would expect to find
when people are storing seeds to eat
them into and then we have even more
unambiguous evidence of seed storage
from context again on those peripheral
areas where we have dry caves and rock
shelters so maybe my favorite artifact
ever is this beautiful bag from Eden's
Bluff in Arkansas that's full of the
seeds of domesticated Keena podium our
quinoa cousin in eastern North America
and then this bundle of may grass is
also from Arkansas and it looks like I
could have harvested it you know a
couple years ago but actually it's about
2,000 years old so we have evidence not
only that people are storing these
plants but that they're storing their
seeds in particular probably both but we
know they were eating them and based on
the domestication syndromes that we see
we can be fairly sure that they were
also planting them so this is gets to
consumption this is a human a 3,000 year
old human feces
human poop and this kind of sealed the
deal I think for convincing
archaeologists in the late 1960s and
early 1970s that these were in fact
crops that people are consuming this
archaeologist Patti Joe Watson led
excavations of salts in Mammoth Cave
which are these deep dry caves in
Kentucky and one of the many things that
they found on there were human feces and
these are you know I've been directly
data they're three thousand years old
and they're full of the seeds of these
plants so hopefully if you didn't
believe that they were eating the seeds
before you're convinced now and then
sort of simultaneously archaeologists
started to send these plant remains to
botanist because back down there really
wasn't any such thing as paleo out the
botany so originally these plant remains
that were coming out of archaeological
sites were analyzed by botanist and what
they did is they referred back to this
you know early literature by people like
Harlan and his colleagues about
domestication syndromes and annual
plants to try and say okay is there
anything about these seeds that were
getting out at the archaeological record
that would indicate that they were
domesticated and we can't see all of
these things in normal archaeological
samples that we get like growth habit or
increase in seeds things like that are
really hard to see in the archaeological
record but there are some things that we
can see usually if we have a well
preserved seeds or fruits such as non
shattering greater seed size loss or
reduction of germination inhibitors and
loss of blooms and other appendages that
would make it difficult to process or
digest seeds so these bonus and and the
eventually archeologists that were
trained as paleo mouths and botanists
started to document on these changes in
the archaeological record so this is
some wheat is the common name for iva
annua this is from their sort of wild
comparative collections about three by
three millimeters as a normal size for a
fruit and then you can see sort of from
the older these dates are a little bit
wrong because this is an old paper but
from a later cake going up to the
Mississippian increases in seed size
over time resulting in giant seated I
have an annual by about a thousand years
ago that's three to four times bigger
than it would be in a wild population so
that's seed size is the key criteria for
identifying domesticated
images of IVA which will become later
important later in this talk for kena
podium the key characteristic although
there are others is a reduction in the
thickness of its testa which makes it
germinate more easily so this is showing
these are old species names but
basically different native phenotypes of
wild kena podium with a thick testa like
40 to 60 microns and then for comparison
Chia
which is a domesticated kina podium
that's grown in Mexico and then this
archeological assemblage from Russel
cave which has even thinner testa than
our modern domesticate Chia down in
Mexico so again this is that for this
species that key criteria is as that
reduction in germination inhibitors and
then slightly less well-known is little
barley several archaeologists have
argued that little barley was also
domesticated either in the southwestern
in the southeast and the argument that
they make is a little bit complex so
these are experimentally burned seeds
that I burned myself this summer so
they're in like various states of
undress and you can see that after
they've been burned you still have the
chaff adhering you still have the Paleo
MLM of the glooms whatever adhering to
the cari OPS's the grain and the same is
true if you try to process little barley
in various ways like soaking it grinding
it pounding it it's really hard to get
everything off of that grain however in
the archaeological record we only find
these grains we never find chaff which
is actually really mysterious weird I
don't think it's been fully explained
but a partial explanation for it is that
there used to be a naked variety of
little barley domesticated like naked
barley in the old world so I'm pretty
convinced by this argument but I think
that we could keep doing more research
about it because it's really weird that
we don't find chef when everyone else in
the world does so this was kind of where
things stood in terms of domestication
research when I started doing this in
2010 so we had really clear good
accepted evidence that some plead Pina
podium were both domesticated based on
changes in seed size and germination
inhibitors and a pretty solid argument
that little barley was as well and then
we had lots of evidence that may grass
was cultivated for a long time even
outside of its natural
no sort of morphological indicators that
it was domesticated and then there was a
rack knotweed which was mysterious and
kind of up in the air when I started
doing this research so I first heard
about this mystery when I was working in
the lower Illinois Valley which is a
really beautiful region has some of the
most productive and valuable farmland in
the United States today and this is kind
of looking out over the floodplain from
the bluff
which is where this little site is
located so this site was somebody's
house just one family's house about a
thousand years ago there were farmers
and one of the things that they were
growing was a was a rock not weed so
this assemblage of a rock not weed was
really really weird-looking um first of
all it's sprouting that's the obvious
thing that's weird about it and I don't
really have time to talk about sprouts
today but if there's anyone in the
audience that study sprouts I would love
to discuss it because I think that one
way that this plant may have been
processed to make it more nutritious and
easier to and easier to eat basically
would be to sprout it so that may be
intentional but there were other things
that were strange about this Eric now
eat and the botanists that analyzed it
in the 1980s basically said this doesn't
look like anything in our comparative
collection it certainly doesn't look
like a wreck that we'd so either it's a
domesticated form of a rock now eat or
else there's something missing from our
comparative collection basically this is
how it stood for 30 years and so when I
saw this as like working on my Master's
are like wow like this is such a neat
little question I can investigate for my
dissertation but it was actually a lot
harder to answer this question that I
anticipated that it would be as it
usually is but but I ended up being able
to convince myself and then eventually
you know a panel of anonymous botanist
that there was in fact an extinct
domesticated subspecies of erect not
weed in eastern North America and it is
the type specimen for this comes from
one of those rock shelter collections in
in Arkansas so in the course of doing
this research and convincing myself that
this was really a domesticated
population was when I first became
interested in plasticity because I was
taking seed samples from you know many
different species of clicking them first
and seeing how there is a ton of
variability within between species and
then eventually once I
you know established myself that I was
working with a wreck not weed from a
wreck now he that was growing in a lot
of different kinds of habitats and
different places and then eventually I
was cultivating it too and I started to
notice that there's a lot of variability
and what I was seeing in terms of seed
morphology depending on what was going
on with the plan so at first I'll admit
that I was just annoyed by plasticity I
saw it as noise and I wanted to be able
to eliminate it as a possible
explanation for what I was seeing in the
archaeological record but as I continued
to study it longer and longer I started
to think that it could possibly be
important for why this plant was
domesticated for how this site was
domesticated so in order to explain kind
of why I think that or using this as an
example I have to explain some things
about this plant because unless there's
weed scientists in the room people
probably don't aren't familiar with it
so it's fruits and flowers all summer
long so this is a typical sort of summer
plant it has pretty much for sure fruits
maturing fruits and flowers all on it
and then right before it dies it does
this thing where it was a big bout of
simultaneous fruiting and then the whole
plant is covered in seeds which is nice
if you're a farmer and you're growing up
recede another important thing about
this plant that you need to understand
is that under normal conditions in its
wild state it produces two different
kinds of fruits so dimorphic a keen a
keen is a type of fruit it produces this
one the tubercle dwarf all summer so if
you were to harvest all of the seeds off
of a plant in the summer they would all
be this form and then it starts to
produce these in the fall but these are
still adhering to the plant and they're
still being produced so any typical
harvest that you take in October and
November is going to be some proportion
of both of these from normal wild
populations um this is just like micro
photographs of the thickness of the
pericarp and just just quickly show the
difference but if you had a better image
like from an SEM or something of the
tuber called more if you could see that
it also has layers of wax which keep
water from getting into the seed and
also mechanically restrict the
germination of these seeds so the weird
thing about the domesticated assemblages
that we find in the archaeological
record there's two differences first of
all there are no tuber called morphs
they're completely missing or at least
there are very very few of them
also the smooth morphs are bigger than
you would really expect them to be my
favorite animation which is which have
been using up for years which is a
classic indicator of domestication and
annual seed crops so this disappearance
of the tubercle morphs is important from
the perspective of farming this crop or
from the perspective of domestication
because there's a really clear
germination heteromorphism between these
fruit types as well as you would expect
the smooth morphs germinate more readily
so in these experiments these seeds were
subjected to sort of standard simulated
winter so they were in moist substrate
at 4 degrees Celsius for 6 weeks and
after that treatment with some
exceptions you know I get pretty good
germination from this move Morris but
the tubercle Morris that's not enough
for them to germinate and then another
difference between them is that they
also grow more slowly once they
germinate probably because less of the
volume of fruit is made up of that
nutritive material that the seedling is
using for its early growth so this is
just visualizing that in a more
quantitative way number of leaves and
height as indicators of how big the
plants are at different times in the
first five weeks of growth and this
becomes important because if you have
human cultivators coming in and thinning
out stands of erect not wheat at any
point during the first five weeks of
growth they're going to remove more of
the seedlings that come from those
tubercle morphs
so if you have a plan in the previous
generation that produced a ton of sweet
most mostly smooth marks it's going to
Pat it's more of its offspring are going
to survive this kind of an activity by
people so okay maybe people were
thinning or maybe they weren't most
gardeners do most farmers and in the
past that practice scatter seeding did
but in the case of a rock not weed I
think it's even more likely that people
were thinning because there's a huge
difference in terms of yield depending
on plant density and part of the reason
why is because the plant produces seeds
and the axles of its branches so the
more highly branched it is the more
seeds it produces so in this case you
have more than twice as much seed and
basically the same amount of space as
these 20 plants produce um and you know
this is just showing that relationship
where the more the more the less dense
the
plants are the more branches they have
and then the more seeds they have and
that's interesting because in a typical
wild stand you're not gonna you're a
very very dense populations of a rock
not weed because they drop hundreds of
seeds right underneath them right so I
don't think it's giving ancient people
too much credit to suppose that they
would have noticed that thinning out a
stand like this could double their yield
right in the course of a single
generation so you know that's a pretty
neat little story of how domestication
occurred and we see this really strong
like kind of beautiful trend with only a
couple of weird things going on where
you have your modern you know a
comparative sample here and then in
chronological order you have fruits
getting bigger until the very end when
maybe some sterilizations is going on
and then these open circles indicate the
smooth morphs
so these later assemblages are almost
completely composed of smooth norms just
ignore that um and and so you know this
is a this is a really kind of classic
like a case of domestication what we
would expect but the problem with this
neat story is that in the course of
doing all this going iraq knotweed and
looking at it in the wild and stuff i
notice some stuff that made me think
that this might not be the end of the
story or it might not be the whole story
and i started to think that plasticity
might be a really important part of the
story so there so i started to look to
what people had been writing about
plasticity and domestication and of
course because I'm an anthropologist I
started with anthropology so one of our
most beloved theorists of domestication
and anthropology is Mindy's Eider who
works on animal domestication in the
Near East and she's been saying for you
know it's been general reason why I have
food and writing the bear appears
because you know it's generally accepted
it has been for a long time that some
animals are more domesticable than
others right like there's a reason why
we don't have domesticated bears all
that would be fantastic if we did but
what Minnie has been arguing for a long
time is that rather than saying okay
this animal is domesticated when we see
a difference in its skeleton in the
archaeological record we should look at
behavioral indicators because there are
a lot of animals that were being penned
we're being brought in captivity or
ridden or milked or any number of really
important behavioral things before we
can see any morphological evidence from
their bodies they were domesticated so I
started thinking okay what's the
equivalent to these kinds of pliability
that we see in our domesticated animals
in the plant world and so I started
reading what evolutionary biologists
have been writing about plasticity and
evolution and realized that it's it
we're in the middle of a big to do about
it with some biologists arguing that the
modern synthesis needs to actually be
revised and updated in this extended
evolutionary synthesis to put more
emphasis on plasticity epigenetics and
niche construction so this is just from
one of the papers you know it's sort of
arguing that looking at three different
genotypes and they're what's called
reaction norms in response to two
different environmental types and to
give you just kind of a concrete example
and are really easy to see one from
erect knotweed we've got these two
populations same time of year only like
an hour drive away from each other and
this one's like a little unbranched herb
and then my plants that I was growing in
the garden are like giant woody shrubs
so um sort of unresolved question with
the this whole how important is
developmental plasticity in evolution
question is how does something that's
originally plastic become fixed which is
genetic assimilation how does that
become a fixed trait and I think the
mechanisms that underlie genetic
assimilation if and when it happens are
really poorly understood and I really
think that domesticates are going to be
the best way to get to the bottom of
this because with domestic kids we have
before and after right we have the wild
progenitor and we have the domesticate
that came from it so we can look at
traits that are originally plastic and
then have become fixed in our domestic
'its and try to understand how that
occurred on one example just you know
there are there are other studies I
could point to but this is one that I
like and I think is cool is on manioc
which in its wild state can be either a
shrub or a vine depending on whether
it's growing in an open or a closed
canopy and it's domesticated state it
can still be a shrub or a vine but it's
much less good at being a vine and
frequently it breaks and falls down
so it's lost some of that plasticity
that it had in its wild state so
according to theorists of genetic
assimilation in order for this to occur
need a plastic trait obviously something
in the environment that changes
permanently because at least
hypothetically if the environment
continues to be unpredictable then it
will continue to be good for the plant
to be able to have these two different
phenotypes and some kind of an
evolutionary cost associated with
maintaining plasticity so the
non-plastic genotype is better than the
plastic one so if we take this example
of the dimorphism the fruit dimorphism
the two different types tuber gold and
smooth morphs the first question asked
is is this plastic and I discovered that
it was completely by accident when my
first experiment with this plant pretty
much utterly failed because I was
interested and you know what was causing
this time morphism and bla bla bla and I
grew these plants in a greenhouse where
they were subjected to 16 hours of light
and 8 hours of darkness no matter what
season it was and direct you know
unlimited light right above them and
what happened was they didn't ever
produce any smooth Mars they just
produce tubercle morphs and it was a
mountain war assemblage the opposite of
the domesticated ones that we're finding
in the archaeological record so it
definitely is plastic and what the first
thing I decided to investigate is what
that has to do with light so just ignore
how really messy this is by redo of this
experiment this year as much nicer
looking but for a first try gave me some
good data and I grew through the the
erect net weed outside and then I had a
shady and a sunny treatment to see if it
was day length strictly day length or
like light availability in general that
had something to do with the production
of these two from worse and what I found
again is that yes it's plastic there are
significant differences between the
percentage of one more for the other
that are produced by plants grown in the
shade versus the Sun the shady plants
produce more of the smooth morphs
but also in general the garden grown
plants produced more of the smooth
morphs than any of the wild populations
that I've looked at so in particular
these are all individual plants these
three plans that produce over
90% smooth moors if I found those in the
archaeological record I would say that
they were domesticated like that's
outside the range of variability that
I've documented in wild populations so
what is going on with these plants I
mean they're growing in a garden but
it's not a particularly well tended game
and so I'm not sure what is causing this
this level of plasticity and is there an
evolutionary cost of maintaining
plasticity yes and I think I've already
talked about this if people are coming
through and thinning out those plants
they're going to provide an advantage
plants that produce more of these smooth
waters from this and then are the
populations subjected to new
environmental conditions so the original
to answer first is where would they be
growing if they weren't in cultivation
and that's actually a really complicated
question because the landscape in my
study area has changed so dramatically
and so it could be a whole other talk
like well how do we reconstruct where
these plants were before the entire
Midwest was taken over by kind of
industrial food production but where
they grow today are in these highly
disturbed frequently flooded kind of
Creek banks and flood plains so I use
this as an example because it
illustrates why I think and this has
been theorized by other AI by plant
biologists why this plant has two
different types of fruits to begin with
right
it grows in an unpredictable environment
and sometimes what happens is like these
plants were coming up in May they just
had their very first little flowers and
then a week later there was like a
really extreme flood that scoured the
riverbank it was under water for over a
month and when I came back there in
October there was no and all that
generation of plants had been wiped out
yet the following year the population
was back so those tubercle dwarfs that
don't germinate very readily there
they're a bet hedging mechanism so that
the population can recover after a
catastrophic event at least in theory so
um again in theory dormancy strategies
like iraq knotweed and other plants that
have this kind of hetero germination
heteromorphism have this strategy of
escaping from unfavorable periods in
time right and so sampling different
growing seasons whereas plants that have
a very strong dispersal mechanism are
same
in different locations in the same
season and these could be seen as sort
of alternative ways of dealing with risk
so it stands to reason that if Iraq not
we'd obtained a new dispersal mechanism
ie humans its its existing dormancy
strategy would become less important for
its survival
so our populations subjected to new
environmental conditions I would say
based on the archaeological record we
can say that yes because we know that
people were taking these plants up out
of the floodplain and clearing locations
on terraces that would otherwise be
stable forest ecosystems to grow these
crops and we know that they were storing
the seeds and keeping them safe which
provides an alternative to storage and
the soil seed bank so in this case that
those typical morphs are no longer
necessary for the survival population
because it's living in a more stable
environment and because of thinning and
cultivation behavior they're actually
detrimental to to the plant
so as I'm discovering all this stuff
about Iraq now and thinking ok maybe
genetic assimilation is part of the
story of how this plant was domesticated
my colleagues were coming to similar
conclusions about two of the other lost
crops so my colleague Liz was work is
working throwing all the last crops in
her garden and down in Arkansas but in
particular she was noticing some fishy
business with IVA and you want some weed
which you can see is dwarfing her in her
garden this is not a normal height for
IVA then my colleague Paul and his
students were growing kina podium oh hi
Oh University and also sampling from a
lot of different wild populations so um
the basis of our project about
plasticity and domestication rested on
three observations that were made Liz in
her garden noticed that over the course
of four growing seasons the IVA started
to spontaneously produce bigger seeds
and this was about any kind of selection
for bigger seems like she wasn't
thinning she wasn't planting them deep
she wasn't doing any of the things that
we thought for generations caused the
increase in seed size and our
domesticated plants and yet if we again
if we found these seeds in the
archaeological record we would say they
were kind of borderline domesticated
like they're definitely above the cutoff
or what we've considered to be
domesticated IVA so what's going on with
that I've already talked a lot about
so I'm not gonna belabor it but again if
I found these particular plants in the
archaeological record I would also say
based on the criteria that I myself just
made up that they're domesticated so you
know I hate to contradict myself so soon
but we may need to kind of either
rethink our defining domestication or
rethink our criteria and finally with
kina podium what we're finding is that
we we knew that some of these seeds that
have thin test has occurred naturally in
wild populations and you can sort of see
them with your naked eyes the ones that
show up is red or yellow instead of
black they have a thinner testa but what
we're seeing harvesting for more
different populations of can podium is
that actually it can be up to you know
like 50 percent of wild plant can have
these on taneous they have these thin
testa's so again we want to figure out
what's well first of all what's going on
with chenopodium because it's mass just
in terms of those species delegations
and things like that but also what sorts
of environmental conditions may be
causing this variability that we see so
these three projects make up this larger
project a palette for selection which we
are doing in collaboration with Logan
Kistler at the Natural History Museum
Smithsonian National Museum of Natural
History and the part of it that I'm
currently executing right now is the
polygamy doing that except messy-looking
experiment that I showed you from st.
Louis with the Sun in the shade and we
are taking RNA samples from leaves
flowers and developing fruits every two
weeks so that we can try and see at what
point this this trigger happens where
the plants start producing these smooth
morphs and if that's happening more so
or earlier in one treatment versus the
other which is a good sort of way to
transition into talking a little bit
about the molecular facets of paleo
ethnobotany
so this is changing really fast ancient
DNA especially human ancient DNA
research has exploded exponentially in
the past five years and I'm hoping that
we're gonna see a similar kind of
explosion of research in ancient plant
DNA but so far in eastern North America
there's already been some cool stuff
it's all been based on chloroplast DNA
so if
and mostly what it's been used for is
biogeography
so um studies of where what you know
ancient populations of squash and how
they're related to to modern populations
of squash and this really cool mystery
about bottle gourds and how they ended
up getting from Africa to North America
10,000 years ago which is a story for
another day
and then biogeography proving that or
demonstrating that kina podium was
independently domesticated in eastern
North America and same thing for
sunflowers so molecular backup for those
being from eastern North America as
opposed to some other region and then
most recently chloroplast DNA has been
used to look at sort of biodiversity in
the ancient biodiversity and so this
study just came out it's my favorite
paper of 2018 and it's showing a couple
a few ancient genomes in here
ancient plasto's I should say and a lot
of historical and ethnographic alene own
sunflower landraces and modern cultivars
and there's a lot of really interesting
things on this paper so I encourage you
to just go read it but one thing that I
really like about it is that it's
showing first of all that we've even
compared to we know we've lost a lot of
agro biodiversity in the past hundred
years but even compared to that there
still are even more ancient losses that
we've suffered so one of these sort of
types is not represented one of the
ancient types it's not represented in
any of the you know modern samples that
we have and also that ancient people
were cultivating more than one land race
in the same place which is cool I mean
it's to be expected but it's nice to
have proof so ancient epigenomics is
just kind of getting started and again
has mostly been deployed on humans not
plants but could be really cool way to
explore plasticity and plant
domestication as well so irony has been
extracted from ancient maize kernels
methyl homes have been reconstructed for
ancient humans and relatives I don't
know how useful this is going to be for
plant investigations since most of our
well-preserved DNA comes from seeds and
seeds are inherently not really doing
much before they germinate but hopefully
maybe we can come up with some
applications for this going forward as
our methods improve
and then another thing that's starting
to come out of the ancient DNA research
for plants is looking at kind of these
deep histories of plants and their
evolution in human communities so this
is sorghum both these studies are about
sorghum this one is kind of showing how
the major land races of sorghum are are
correlated with ethno-linguistic groups
across the African continent so kind of
looking at the connections between human
cultural movement and interaction and on
the one hand and agro biodiversity on
the other hand and this one's looking it
is a huge amount of ancient plant
genomes in comparison to other studies
and what is showing is that these really
well differentiated land races that we
have in sorghum are probably pretty
recent because all of the ancient
genomes are kind of falling into this
undifferentiated
area and there are other conclusions in
this paper that I can't don't have time
to get into that basically indicate that
sorghum the the bottleneck that were
sorghum lost biodiversity with respect
to its wild ancestor didn't occur at the
beginning of its domestication it
occurred thousands of years later so
that's kind of contradicting what we
have thought about domestication in the
past and it's highlighting the
importance of instead of looking at
domestication like oK we've identified
when this was domesticated and then we
have like when the early botanist went
out and collected and everything in
between is just awash there's a lot of
kind of evolution in different
trajectories that were happening in
between those two points that need to be
investigated
so um by way of wrapping up in time for
some questions I just want to just show
you some of the other things that I'm
doing and as I said I don't have like
concrete results yet because we're still
doing this stuff but one of the things
that we're looking at is how to get
these things to germinate it's not that
easy to get wild plants to germinate in
comparison to crops and that's probably
something that ancient people struggled
with and they started to actually plant
these so you know we started over the
winter with just doing like simulated
winter treatments so that we could
figure out how to even get any of the
seeds to germinate for big experiments
this spring but this winter we're going
to do some other things to try and get
better germination rates and from a
practical standpoint this is important
because if other people are gonna pick
this up and do research about it they
have to be able to get these things
to Germany it's it's such a headache in
it it really can slow down the
experiments or ruin them it doesn't work
and then you can see like this
experiment that I spent such a long time
sort of setting up is right here back
here but the majority of the area that
we're cultivating is actually what I'm
just calling general experiments and
what we're looking at there is just the
effects of multi cropping and plant
spacing on yield and just plant health
plant size so one of the things that we
think based on you know historically
known and currently conducted Native
American agriculture is that it's
probably a multi crop system there there
wasn't very much mono cropping going on
in the new world and so what kind of
synergies there may have been between
these plants in the past we don't know
how well they would do with each other
versus if they're grown by themselves
and I took this picture because these
are the two oldest lost crops can you
podium an IVA and they grow in very
similar types of environments naturally
and they seem to be doing very well
together out in the field so we'll see
what kind of yields we get from them
when they're when they're in a little
community versus by themselves and then
this is something that I haven't really
had time to circle back to in like
months because I've been out in the
field all the time but we're taking
these kind of overhead shots of the
plots every week so that we can
hopefully get the computer to learn how
to pick out the different species and
calculate how much of the canopy they're
making up so if any I know some people
here do that because I've seen posters
around so if anyone has good ideas for
me about how to operationalize that I
would love to hear hear them and then
finally we've noticed some kind of
strange things about the lost crops and
this will just be my final kind of take
so the may grass which I haven't said
really anything about it's called may
grass because it produces seeds in May
usually here are produce seeds in like
mid-june because it doesn't usually grow
in New York but regardless it produces
seeds in the summer and so some
archeologists have been wondering for
years if it would be possible to get to
crops out of May grass like if you
harvested the seeds in May and then
replanted them could you get a fall crop
but it turns out that it's actually even
easier than that because if you just
keep the area around the May grass
weeded it will die in the middle of the
summer and then spontaneously regenerate
in the fall so
we thought that these plants had
completely smashed and were dead and
then a few weeks ago they started
sending up new seed heads and now we're
getting a second crop of May grass out
there so that's nice if you're a farmer
you don't to do anything so you know
keep it clear
and then our IVA was struggled a lot
like it really didn't do well at all and
I think the reason why is because we're
way up on top of a hill on Caldwell Road
and I didn't and we had a really dry
June and it just didn't germinate well
at all so this picture is kind of harder
to interpret but this is the lowest plot
like it's probably about a meter lower
than the other one's not very extreme
slope but this is the only one of these
abandoned plots were nothing germinated
that had any ayah this is IVA right here
at all germinate in it so that little
difference in altitude and soil Marsh
moisture I think although I wasn't
directly measuring that is making a huge
difference in terms of whether or not
this plant can germinate and grow which
is important for reconstructions of how
this agricultural system worked because
if people were trying to grow these
plants together but one of them couldn't
tolerate being you know taken out of its
sort of marshy environment then that
presents a constraint for the
agricultural system so on that note I
guess I will take questions for the next
five minutes or so before I do that I
just want to thank my especially thank
my students one of whom is here Andrea
and Peter for just being awesome the
summer and keeping the experiments
running when I've been out of town and
just being really great thanks Andrea
all right anyone have questions is there
a salinity factor here as well because
both opposed I have a no upper salt
marsh um maybe I mean it's definitely a
factor to be explored although many of
the places that I found them growing are
not particularly salty and you know like
out in the wilds of the Midwest but it's
definitely one of many factors that
could be affecting how well they're
doing and because I really only had the
time and resources to grow them in one
location I really wanted to do two
different locations the summer but it
was just I just didn't have enough
manpower basically but yeah the soil
soil could be a huge
factor that I really want to look into
in the future I'm assuming that the
indigenous people who said on the king
of podium and IVA were doing so because
they were nutritionally rich has any
research been done looking at the
nutrient content of the more ancient
seed versus their contemporary varieties
yeah so there has been very limited
research done on the nutritional
properties of these plants there's one
paper that looks at kind of like gross
nutritional properties like protein
versus fat versus carbohydrates this is
something that has been constrained by
lack of seeds too right like we want to
do cooking experiments and nutritional
experiments for these plants but so far
like good farmers we had to first see to
our needs for next year in terms of
planting so one of the things that I
didn't talk about but I'm hoping to get
out of this is we're also just growing a
bunch of plants in the greenhouse or
seed so that we can do this kind of
stuff and I and and it may be possible
to do some kind of nutritional analyses
of the ancient domestic it's to the ones
that are from the desiccated collections
I just don't know enough about how that
works to to know for sure I need a good
collaborator yeah okay so Dan is asking
basically why these crops fall out of
cultivation if it was environmental
cultural or some kind of combination of
the two and this is a huge question that
I would love to do like a large a
long-term project on so one of the
biggest problems I think that we have
with answering this question is that
archaeologists really like to date the
earliest occurrence of things but
they're not at all interested in dating
the latest occurrence of things so we
actually don't really know when these
plants
out of cultivation because people aren't
like trying to find the latest
assemblage and data what I personally
think based on you know a sort of
cursory literature review is that there
were at least some farmers that were
still growing these crops right up until
European colonization began and that
that knowledge was lost along with
probably lots of other knowledge as
communities are moving around and people
and work and so much work fare and
destruction was happening right so I
think that was going on but it is
undeniable that there were definitely
less people growing them by the time of
European colonization and had been
before amazed beans and squash arrived
so I do think that to a certain extent
once people had functioning Mazal and
races that like worked for this climate
it was a better crop i I do think that's
part of the answer because people all
over the world have adopted maize
because it's highly productive but
there's probably other things going on
too and some communities like that one
where I was like ignore this yeah so one
of the things that's kind of like an
archeological detail has to do with that
so this this is some allege here that's
not domesticated that looks like it's
even smaller than the wild population it
might not even be the right species like
these people might have been just
cultivating the wrong species
um I say wrong because it was different
from what everybody else was ever
cultivating these are early adopters of
maize this culture is called fort
ancient and it's a approximately
thousand-year-old culture in the Ohio
River Valley that's known for adopting
maize and as a staple crop really early
before other people had switched over so
it doesn't really surprise me that their
knowledge of a rock not wheat and their
seed stock wasn't very good considering
that there was so focused on maize so
there was a lot of variability too I
guess it's not really an answer but
somebody you should write a dissertation
about it someday we got one more in the
back and then okay
so the shattering is the thing that
people who study serial domestication in
the old world that's their favorite
criteria because it's less like
wishy-washy than seed size and they
don't actually use a seed they use the
chaff so they'll look at the morphology
of the reyga's just to see whether it
was like a robust connection that had to
be like broken or whether it was like I
don't have an image of it right now but
it's it's based on experimental studies
that where they've looked at the
morphology and wild and domesticated
types and there may be something
somewhere for these crops nobody's
looked at it as far as I know tried to
but the thing is a lot of them are into
hissing in their wild state which is
also a story for another day so Geneva
you have any questions its buckwheat old
world or new world sorry wheat old world
or new world buckwheat is old world and
it's domestication is fairly not well
understood compared to a lot of other
old world crops it was probably a pretty
late domesticate and I think the latest
is that it was probably domesticated on
the Tibetan Plateau this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu